come on in and warm your frozen boots by
the fire Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you a recent halftone
patch appears to include information
regarding the games next major expansion
data found within the update which is
now live points23 new card backs one
named as molten core another named after
the feared legendary ragnaros and one
called the golden celebration every
month Blizzard adds a new card back to
hearthstone and in this case it appears
that Ragnar us will be the latest design
and golden celebration is likely to be a
reward marking the one-year anniversary
of the game which officially launched on
March 11 last year however the internal
developer notes attached to the other
card backs appear to hint at the rumored
next adventure mode according to the
decryption of the patch data undertaken
by hothead calm the molten core back is
fixed with a developer note which reads
purchase brm pre-sales hands analyzing
this belief it's a reference to
Blackrock Mountain ozone in World of
Warcraft which is suspected to be the
setting for the new adventure mode
Blizzard has yet to comment on this but
pc gamer notes that Blizzard will be
making a pax east announcement next
Friday path stones previous adventure
mode the curse of naxxramas which I
still haven't finished it was also based
on his own in World of Warcraft one of
the game's key developers ben brode
recently told GameSpot that adding a new
adventure mode was a case of correct
timings our goal going forward is to
figure out the right pace of adding in
more expansions I'm adventures he said
we have to time it so that players are
ready for a new batch of cards we're not
going to go in too fast either so what
do you think is this an indication of a
new adventure mode or something else
entirely how's your mana curve looking
for all the latest on ha stone make sure
you head over to gamespot com jobs done
you